what is happening there reject nation we
got ourselves a cinematic reveal trailer
for star wars eclipse our star wars
expert john humphrey is here with us
today because this i hear good things
about takes place during the high
republic what's that all about john 200
years before the events of the phantom
menace greg it's when the jedi were at
their most powerful sky
man man republic's doing wow
off all that research oh man all those
years years of reading
before
let's do this
[Music]
wow
unreal
engine
[Music]
okay
wow
yoda
star wars taiko drummer brigade
hey
[Music]
rise
this is just the muscle twitches man
let's go to war people
[Music]
harkonnen
that
[Music]
love this yeah
game trailers the cinematic game shows
of star wars are so good yeah man every
star wars movie should just be a
cinematic game it might as well be at
this point you saw that atmosphere it's
pretty gnarly to watch this trailer when
you know like
dude came out this year and dune being a
franchise that inspired star wars in a
lot of ways not the only thing inspired
star wars but one of them and then to
watch this and be like this is the first
time in a while i've seen something from
star wars where the mood you brought up
like the atmosphere feels very dune
reminiscent
out of anything i've seen in a while so
i loved getting those real dark moody
haunting vibes calling this eclipse so
this is like the high republic this is
like the peak of the galactic right this
is when everything's at its best and
you're looking at the glory to behold
the darkness is soon going to eclipse
yes the beauty the joy the light and i i
loved the way they thematically handled
this one and then you could feel that
percolating build throughout but john
being the expert what's going on here oh
man you know you got the galactic empire
you know slowly amassing their forces
you know to you know set in upon the
republic because obviously ideologically
there's a big disagreement there and i
mean we saw some jedi in this trailer
this is like the time at which they are
you know the most comfortable in their
seat of power and control throughout the
galaxy and uh you know we obviously saw
master yoda from behind for a little bit
we got uh
glimpses of some different aliens that
you know we would uh recognize from star
wars films i mean the interesting thing
to me about this is that you have a lot
of stuff that is hearkening to an older
time in the uh galaxy yeah but uh you
also have a lot of familiar stuff for
fans of the films to look at and go oh
hey it's it's that alien species of
creature or hey it's that droid it looks
kind of like c-3po he's all banged up
and stuff so you know this looks like
i'm gonna wait and see if there's a
story trailer or something but as an
atmospheric dip into the past it really
does feel like a dip love the look
watching just those two jedi sparring on
that big old bridge i haven't heard a
word
totally honest
you don't have to man it's all in the
feeling as long as you feel me and you
you'll soak up my expertise throughout
most everything you were saying though
i'll assume i did plus it's nice to know
that there are other musicians in the
star wars universe besides the cantina
band you know we got like a whole taiko
drumming unit you know nice to see when
did you become so knowledgeable about
the galaxy oh man how did this all come
into play just just 20 minutes ago man i
just i had a vision from beyond and i
was like oh you're a real race guy i
watched star wars you know i just
downloaded it into my i am i'm a mary
sue when it comes to this star wars
stuff all right i i didn't have any
training and then all of a sudden oh oh
i'm just dodging blasts left and right
and slicing people in half you know the
last game i played was uh star wars jedi
falling order still waiting for the damn
announcement for the second one in terms
of here i'm well most curious to know is
what's the gameplay going to be like
can't be just jet fun or because you're
looking at so much different set pieces
you could you could deal with uh
probably close to something like
battlefront but then if you're playing
as jedi i'm not sure from what they gave
us here it seems like something where
you would be jumping yeah they show you
some dog fights they show you some
lightsaber fights they show you armies
so i have to imagine that all levels of
combat will be on the table yeah
because that's part of the fight
and especially if there's a vr component
oculus you know
you know that'd be pretty sick this is
what every star wars video should be
it's probably like every 1800 game
trailers that bring back dash retina
while
bring back dash rendar all that talk and
you not once pointed out
newt gunray oh i was saving that best
part for break it down hey man it's nice
to see him back from the
phantoms knowing that i guess he's got a
very very long lifespan headed into that
movie
proper start with like clone wars and
yeah i think he actually showed him a
bad match too yeah anyway guys and he's
here 200 years ago
anyway guys thanks so much for being
here star wars eclipse i think the sonic
trailer just drops that's going to go
first
subscribe click that bell
everett pixel my baker john you wanted
to shout him out absolutely because what
day could be more perfect to celebrate
the might contained within tiny little
pixels than the video game awards i hope
you're a gamer that's what your name tag
suggests to me but if you're not a gamer
why don't you pop over into our patreon
page pick any video and just let us know
what you're about man are you about
pixels in terms of photography are you a
fan of the movie pixels starring adam
sandler with all the classic video game
characters showing up if you're a gamer
that's got to be like the utmost
heavenly place just like at a private
screening watching pixels all by
yourself just soaking in the reverence
for the gaming culture and community
everett
yeah you're the baker
of the joyous love in my heart and uh i
hope that you're having a nice holiday
season buddy you
are the real mighty one stay safe out
there be well everett
yes
[Music]